so what do you think about CrossFit
scenes you do a lot of the same
movements and workout schemes so
CrossFit
I think CrossFit is a is a solid base
for things I also think that CrossFit
actually deserves a pretty good amount
of credit for getting the general
populace of the world moving in the
right direction when it comes to fitness
I've been doing crossfit type stuff
before there was such a thing as
CrossFit I mean the movements that you
use in CrossFit are movements that have
been invent anything new right but they
did reintroduce it's kind of like the
Gracie family to be honest with you and
and there's you know both the Gracie
family and CrossFit in my opinion are
responsible for really a paradigm shift
in those two arenas the arena fitness
and the arena of martial arts if you
looked at martial arts in the 70s and
the 80s what was it it was told it was
karate it was kung fu
it was Aikido it was traditional martial
arts it was not full-contact sparring it
was it was just radically different than
what it is now median that came from the
Gracie family who created the UFC and
broadcasted and got the information out
there and spread the word of jiu-jitsu
which part of jiu-jitsu
and part of the UFC is that you have to
learn to wrestle and you have to learn
to strike so that all kind of came
afterwards but it's all related to the
initial the initial birth of of UFC and
Gracie jiu-jitsu and that's the same
thing in my opinion with CrossFit you
know CrossFit again or people doing
Olympic lifting years ago yes they were
but it's a very small if you okay you
look at the the martial arts schools in
the 70s look at Fitness places in the in
the 70s and 80s it was those weird you
know machines and aerobic stuff and the
thing that women would like tie around
their stomachs and would like shake them
I mean just all kinds of bizarre
bizarre stuff and that's just stuff that
was just ineffective and so I think
CrossFit deserves credit for spreading
you know the the knowledge of squatting
and cleaning jerks and pull-ups and
muscle ups and all those things and so
you know again I like I said it's you've
got their word decathletes before
CrossFit there were Olympic lifters
gymnasts before CrossFit and those
people were incredibly fit but CrossFit
popularized those activities and those
exercises more than anybody else was
able to I mean CrossFit is popular and
jiu-jitsu is popular I mean if you look
at the number of jujitsu schools and
CrossFit boxes in the country they're
probably of the same growth pattern so I
definitely give CrossFit credit for
bringing that kind of well-balanced
fitness to the forefront and I think the
programming you know is fine
for me it's a little bit too random I
like stuff to be a little bit more
scheduled I guess you could say and
sometimes I need more volume than what
they have and I think you need more
focus to get really good at some things
you need to focus trait CrossFit would
prescribe I think that you know now
people realize you know for a while they
kind of held the line of like no all you
need to do is what it says to do on the
CrossFit workout of the day just like in
the beginning jiu-jitsu Gracie jiu-jitsu
said all you need to do is just do
gracie jiu-jitsu and clearly both those
attitudes are wrong you know what you
really need to do is get that base and
then open your mind open your mind up
and you get to know yourself what you're
you get to know your own physicality
after a while and then you know what
your weaknesses are you know what hurts
you and you know what you can do more of
and you know what you should do less of
so I think that as a base you know like
if someone just randomly says you know
hey I never worked out before what
should I do
I think CrossFit is a fine place to
point you know there's some other really
good stuff out there but you know if you
it costs what's a good one
and I think it's a good starting point
it's gonna teach you the basics of
squats and pull-ups and dips and there's
gonna be a million people that are gonna
say they don't really teach you Olympic
lifting properly and you need to learn
better form I get it right don't if you
want to learn to be an Olympic lifter
the CrossFit is not gonna be the best
place to learn to be an Olympic lifter
you need to go get an Olympic lifting
coach if you want to be a great gymnast
you need to get a gymnastics coach but
if you want an introduction to stuff a
basic introduction then I think it's a
solid four and again I think you need to
give it credit for what it did and then
most important you need to keep an open
mind that things change and you will you
have to change we all have to change and
adapt and grow and evolve so that you
can become better so that's my opinion
yeah the CrossFit undeniably what it
what it did is took working out and some
CrossFit workouts can be hard I did
CrossFit for a little bit and even for
someone who's like in pretty good shape
like they can be hard and what an
element of CrossFit that I'm not sure if
this was intended from the beginning but
it got this way quick is is kind of the
group so our environment you know so
what it did was it turned it into acting
now it's a sport it's a straight-up
sport now and it really all it is is
exercising the sport of exercising being
the guy who wins the CrossFit Games
what's he called the fittest guy he's
fit so it brought Fitness into this more
of an activity to do rather than okay
you got to do this shorty kind of you
got a workout it made it into like an
activity like boom and not just okay I'm
gonna go do some easy stuff with you
know the girls on the weekend it's it's
for real you know like a hard workout
gonna put you through you get in a group
in a CrossFit situation and they're
gonna be yelling supporting you and
it's way easier to stick with a workout
program when you have people supporting
you and they support you like for real
support you they're yelling how you
finish beneficial all this stuff and
you're way more likely to achieve
success rather than someone's like oh
here you're gonna make it to the gym
today oh yeah maybe maybe not or
whatever and they give you good guidance
so again it made it made Fitness one
quote Fitness be popular you know this
is this cool thing you know and a
community you know in a way that I don't
it's I mean like you said there's there
was already some of these but they're
like okay bodybuilding and you know I
don't know maybe summer aerobics but it
didn't have that sense of community like
yeah that's it there's so much more part
I mean you look at a company like rogue
fitness yeah I mean they didn't exist I
don't know five years ago but he will
like I have my old squat rack thing was
ancient right and it was kind of hard to
get back in the day you want to squat
rack now boom well rope fitness is a
boom oh there you go yeah they're gonna
send it to you it's gonna show up in
your house and in three days yeah and
they're selling hundreds of thousands of
them I'm sure and and why is that
they're selling rings they're selling
boxes for boxers are just bumper plates
bumper plates used to be you'd never see
them like I had well I'd bumper plates
in the Y where I grew up
yeah and there was you know two guys
that would actually Olympic lifts and
you go oh wow that's cool but never in
the gym now you go to hate almost any
gym now no no hey almost I shouldn't say
that because the the 24-hour fitness
type Globo gyms if they do oh do that oh
yeah I've been in one of the long time
in there's over here and I said 24-hour
Fitness membership I'll go there you
know from time to time yeah
all of them have straight up you know
protein Greg yeah he's a trainer and
he's at the Balboa one big full-on Bray
you want to get a courier cross been on
you can go to 24 Hour Fitness versus
more crowded that's different the
culture is different right which is a
big part of CrossFit as well but
facility wise oh yeah
bumpers all up in there yeah so that's
that's that's all thanks to CrossFit
right yeah that's exactly your point you
know
good deal